voici les chars anti aériens de l'armée
allemande qui seront livrés dans les
prochains jours à l'ukraine des blindés
vétuste mais un geste symbolique pour
berlin qui avait jusqu'à présent été
timide dans son aide militaire à l'armée
ukrainienne un soutien qui s'ajoute aux
nombreuses livraisons d'armes
américaines à l'ukraine depuis le début
du conflit pour le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères il existe désormais
un risque de troisième conflit mondial
le danger sérieux réel il existe et il
ne peut pas être sous-estimée
une quarantaine de pays occidentaux se
réunit aujourd'hui à ramstein en
allemagne objectif décider d'une
nouvelle tactique pour renforcer les
défenses ukrainienne depuis le début du
conflit les etats unis ont déjà fourni à
l'ukraine plus de 5 milliards d'euros
d'armes et de munitions loin devant la
france et l'allemagne plus de 100
millions d'euros plus de 200 millions
d'euros pour le royaume-uni et l'estonie
selon le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky tous les pays sont désormais
concernés par ce conflit
tous les pays dont le monde même ceux
qui ne nous soutenaient pas ouvertement
s'accordent désormais à dire que c'est
en ukraine que se joue le destin de
l'europe le destin de la sécurité
mondiale et le sort du système
démocratique
de nouvelles frappes russes ont eu lieu
ces derniers jours à kharkiv dans le
nord-est du pays faisant au moins cinq
morts et neuf blessés depuis le début du
conflit plus de 5 millions d'ukrainiens
ont fui leur pays selon les nations
unies près de 3000 civils ont déjà perdu
la vie